Jim where are you what's going on thanks
so much it is great to be here thank you
for having me
Conan oh for God's sake oh it's good to
be here I'm a big fan of your show okay
this you have it on it says show on a
piece of paper okay uh-huh
although excuse me okay yes all right
yeah no no just a minute no yes no
you're talking into a zucchini yes he is
wearing the shirt of a 12 year old boy
[Laughter]
we've got a lot to talk about you we've
known each other I think for over 60
years
all right 65 years
what is that is that urine in a jar I've
been busy today so huge here urinating
into a jar on zoom' these are human
eyeballs oh this is uh I had some dilly
beans from aunt Marty a friend of mine
who makes he sent me some of these these
uh dilly beans amazing okay okay sorry
gone no no this is all gold Raymond who
put these stairs here oh look at that
you got some stairs there it's hard to
look that's the laziest going down
stairs I've ever done because I don't
want to move out of my chair and I think
I don't have the quad strength so I'm
just gonna do it while it's remaining in
a chair you know it's ridiculous how are
you Jim we've known each other as I said
for like 60 years and we've liked each
other for months
yes how are you holding up in quarantine
how are you doing old friend there's you
know I just I just want I'm here with my
family which I I love them dearly and
I just want I want someone to go to bed
I I want I'm tired and nobody goes to
sleep
it used to be people would go to bed I'm
the only one that goes to bed i nap
during the day and I'm still the first
one to go to bed I'm tired yeah I
I know you have a very large family how
many people we talking here how many
kids you got there are five children and
they're just and no one sleeps no one
goes to bed no one they're just they're
not there like my wife's there you know
they don't need sleep there they want to
talk they want to do things it's like I
don't know I shouldn't have had a family
I don't know if it's too late now but no
there's still things you could do
they're not legal they're not moral but
this we can talk when this interview is
over there's still a way out
remember when you told me you thought
Scott Peterson was a good guy remember
that yeah yeah I remember going on it
I remember going on at great length
about how I killed this pregnant wife
was a good guy and I yeah I said that
guy just I said he feels like a quality
quality chump he does that's what I said
yeah I think I was a mistake I think I
think that's wrong okay okay so what are
you doing you're not sleeping you've got
at last count 15 kids a wife
it won't sleep you must be losing your
mind is there anything that gives you
peace during these these strange times
were in Jim I I spend time in my garden
that never used to happen before and you
know what I like about my garden is my
family's not there that's what I like
about my garden oh that's really cool
hello okay no yeah the interviews it's I
don't know how long I'm just I'm just
phoning it in
don't worry I'll be done okay you know I
love you too um the zucchini bit is this
this is something a bit I always go to
it you know you're holding
hold on this is a big phone call hello
yeah no it's not working
none of the bits are no okay hold on can
I say something are these these must be
coming from your garden is that
right is that way you have all these
massive vegetables yes these are and by
the way do you remember in in happy days
when Ralph's mouth used to say I still
got it
mm-hmm I know I still got it
I still got it I don't I don't why would
a young child be wondering if he still
got it
anyway I just I don't know I don't know
how to answer that question because I
just noticed that they put makeup on my
face but I'm wearing a short sleeve
shirt and they didn't touch my arms and
the disparity is shocking between my
face and my arm this is a clown show
here I'm an abandoned theater and I look
like Lorenzo Lamas except my arms look
like they've had chemotherapy I don't
know what's happening and I apology and
you're in a steak restaurant or some
kind of steak house and when Wilmer
Valderrama gets finds out you took his
shirt he's gonna be upset okay you win
you win